نحن في مدينه عثمانيه مركز محافظه عثمانيه
في هذه المنطقه الضرر كبير جراء الزلزال
الاول الذي هز مناطق واسعه من جنوب تركيا
هذا المبنى كان مؤلفا من اربعه وعشرين
طابقا انهار بشكل كامل في لحظه وقوع
الزلزال فرق الانقاذ تعمل منذ
فجر يوم امس من هذا المبنى تم انتشار حتى
الان اكثر من عشره قتلى وتقول فرق الانقاذ
انها تشتبه بوجود 30 شخصا لا يزالون تحت
الانقاض الاليات
الثقيله بدات تعمل بعد ان تاكد لفرق
الانقاذ عدم وجود ناجين تحت الانقاض طبعا
المنطقه
الاضرار في المنطقه واسعه جدا ليس فقط
مباني المدمره هذا المبنى على سبيل المثال
به تصدع كبيره وقايل للسقوط ايضا هناك
دمار كبير على صعيد الممتلكات والسيارات
والمزيد من الاليات في هذه الاثناء تدخل
الى هذا المبنى
ليتمكنوا من سحب او محاوله انتشال الضحايا
العالقين تحت الانقاض كما قلنا فرق
الانقاذ تستبعد وجود احياء من هذا المبنى
ولذلك تم جلب الاليات الثقيله للعمل في
هذا الموقع العدد الكلي للقتله في المدينه
لم يتم احصائه بعد صباح هذا اليوم احد
الشبان انتشل من تحت انقاذ احد المباني في
اخر هذا الشارع الذي نقف فيه وكان لا يزال
على قيد الحياه بعد مرور اكثر من 26 ساعه
من وقوع الزلزال الاول الكبير عند وصولنا
الى هذا المكان كانت هناك قافله كبيره من
سيارات الاسع تتجه الى المدينه وايضا
المزيد من فرق الانقاذ هناك منازل وابنيه
مدمره في اكثر من موقع في مدينه عثمانيه
المدينه شبه خاليه تقريبا الاشخاص الذين
ترونهم هنا اما يشاركون بعمليات الانقاذ
او لهم اشخاص
عائلات احباء ربما عالقنا تحت الركام ركام
هذا المبنى
حاله من الترقب تسود هذه المدينه جميع
المحال مقفله حتى المحال الاساسيه او التي
تقدم خدمات اساسيه هناك مخبز واحد يعمل في
هذه المدينه وهناك العشرات ان لم يكن اكثر
من ذلك من المواطنين يصطفون للحصول على
الخبز هذا اليوم ذلك ان الامه المحل تضررت
او الابنيه التي تتواجد فيها تلك المحل قد
تضررت وتكون ايله للسقوط سلام الجزيره من
بلده عثمانيه جنوب تركيا